[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back thanks for
thanks for hanging in with us uh we're
gonna start the [ __ ] list roundup where
we round up all the tweety tweets and
attorney trends that's probably gonna be
the show today because we just have so
[ __ ] much of this stuff
um out there today and then i wanna rail
on some [ __ ] that i forgot over the
weekend the main thing is
i wanted to talk about yesterday [ __ ]
forgotten about it yeah mj
alpha cut carlson there you go
perfect hashtag get that [ __ ] [ __ ]
trending robin says let's [ __ ] go
let's do this
um mj says
she loves the [ __ ] army yes [ __ ] them
all right so so you guys may have heard
that tucker carlson has a thing for the
green m m i don't know if you heard this
or not um apparently
he he really gets off on the green
eminem um and he's really [ __ ] upset
now that he can't have his m m porn i
don't know if this is like he separates
out the green m m's because he watches
the [ __ ] cartoon and sees that that
the eminent has sexy shoes on or
something so i don't know if he's like
he's like pulling out the green m m's
and putting him in his own bowl and
jerking off on the ball i don't know
what the [ __ ] he's doing
but he's really [ __ ] upset that the
green m m is gonna have tennis shoes on
instead of high heels now and it's just
not as sexy the ass of the eminem the
ass of the eminem just is not gonna look
the same what is [ __ ] with these
people
what in the actual [ __ ] are these people
doing let's let's see if we can find
this [ __ ] clip of carlson and the m
m's
it's just absolutely [ __ ] ridiculous
that we even have to [ __ ] do this i
can't even believe that i have to
[ __ ] search a goddamn video of tucker
carlson
cucking on the [ __ ] green m m it's
just i i can't even
it's it's
it's [ __ ] beyond parody
oh
tucker [ __ ] carlson you gotta be
kidding me okay let's let's go to this
thing and see see what we got here
let's uh let's make this bigger i
definitely want to clown this
[ __ ] properly
uh right wing cope here says tucker
carlson is outraged that m m's don't
make him horny enough anymore
oh my god oh this [ __ ] guy how in the
[ __ ]
oh
[Music]
i don't know how we made it this far in
humanity really honestly to the point to
where tucker carlson has a [ __ ] show
that millions of people watch every
goddamn day they believe every [ __ ]
stupid thing this idiot says
and this dumb [ __ ] is on his show
talking about how the ass of the eminem
just isn't good enough for him anymore
because they drew the eminem with tennis
shoes on instead of [ __ ] high heels
and the liberals the liberals are gonna
take sex out of everything what the [ __ ]
are you talking about this is the
dumbest [ __ ] thing i've ever heard of
in my life liberals liberals are the
ones that don't want porno liberals are
the ones that don't want things to be
sexy liberals are the ones that don't
want to show [ __ ] skin and nudity get
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ] you
[ __ ] have been bitching and
moaning and complaining the last [ __ ]
half century
about [ __ ] porno and you got josh
holly bitching up porno's the biggest
[ __ ] thing ever there's white dudes
jacking off then it's making white dudes
look [ __ ] fragile and weak
because they play video games and jack
off all day
you [ __ ] have been obsessed
with people's sexuality for for a whole
[ __ ] half century
no one else gives a [ __ ] about someone's
sexuality if you if you are an eminem
sexual
carlson it's okay we're not gonna
[ __ ] judge you man if you if the m
m's make you [ __ ] horny fine whatever
everyone's got their [ __ ] kink
everybody
we're not going to judge you
but when you go on your tv show and
you're saying stupid [ __ ] like oh
liberals trying to cancel eminem's
because i want him sexy because i gotta
have some
candy porn or some [ __ ] i don't know
what the [ __ ] he's talking about let's
listen to this [ __ ] idiot
here we go
the other big change is that the brown
eminem has quote transitioned from high
stilettos to lower block i love the i
love the [ __ ] word transition there
too
right
like he's really this is this [ __ ]
matt walsh
matt walsh alpha cuck [ __ ] where they're
[ __ ] pissed off
about trans women because they just
might go in a bar and pick up on an m m
and that m m's wearing high heels now
god damn it but what what happens when i
get that eminem home and it transitions
into tennis shoes what the [ __ ] then huh
this is this [ __ ] fragile white male
[ __ ] scared of
women having a penis that they like and
they think is gorgeous and all of a
sudden oh my god it might have been a
man they're they [ __ ] can't handle it
they are [ __ ] weak and they're
[ __ ]
it's just ridiculous this is i can't
even believe that i gotta have this
candy and sexy shoes is highly offensive
what the f that's the [ __ ] i didn't
make that up that's not [ __ ] edited
that's what they had on the screen [ __ ]
heels
also less sexy that's progress
m m's will not be satisfied until every
last cartoon character is deeply
unappealing and totally androgynous
until the moment you wouldn't want to
have a drink with any one of them what
the [ __ ] are you talking about dude
having a drink with an eminem
who the [ __ ] who the
[ __ ] plans a date like is there like an
eminem dating app where you swipe right
or swipe whatever it is swipe right
swipe left
i don't know maybe you got sticky
[ __ ] fingers from the candy or
something else tucker carlson
what the what the hell is what the [ __ ]
is this [ __ ] this video has got four and
a half four almost four and a half
million views by the way let me show you
the
let's let's remove the banner at the
bottom
see this guy's got four and 4.2 million
views
of this [ __ ] cucking
on [ __ ] m ms
what is wrong with this [ __ ]
jesus christ dude you got one of the
biggest audiences in the goddamn country
you can't [ __ ] find more [ __ ] to talk
about than how you want to beat off to
eminem's jesus christ when you're
totally turned off
we've achieved equity they've won
the other big change is that the brown
eminem has quote transition
oh my god
so it's the brown one that he's
concerned about not the green one i
thought it was the green one
i i swore it was the green one
that was the you know i had the the
female him and i don't know i don't know
i i wasn't watching them and in porn
i don't go you know
watch m m porn
like
most most [ __ ] human beings watch
other human beings in porn not [ __ ] m
ms what is this guy doing what the hell
is over on reddit you guys ever been on
reddit you know these [ __ ] alpha
cucks over there running around on
reddit and these other [ __ ] platforms
what are they doing over there there's
gotta be some kind of i don't know
oh tucker carlson you're a
sick sick individual let's see what else
is in this thread here let's get this
thread uh cause i i'm not done
i'm not done with this [ __ ] yet
let's see
hang on
there we go okay what else is in this
thread this tucker
carlson eminem's
let's see what else we got here
what's brooklyn dad defiancy tucker
carlson wants people to think democrats
are coming for your sexy m m's but
really it's just tucker who's coming for
them
[Music]
[ __ ]
oh my god can you imagine this guy
standing in his [ __ ] closet
trying to hide from trying to hide from
his wife
um with his with his bowl of m m's jesus
christ um looks like chip franklin had a
video here let's watch chip's video
maybe he liked the sexy boots tucker
carlson needs a hobby the green eminem
you will notice is no longer he's got
hobbies
tucker's upset at m m's for making the
sexy m m's less sexy it's nice dude get
your pants back on it's candy every last
cartoon character is deeply unappealing
i was on the road for 14 years and not
once did i ever think of eating an m m
maybe the occasional peppermint patty
but that was before i was married this
is the whole sub republican attack on
democrats and i guess it makes sense i
think peppermint patties are much sexier
than
them also less sexy another symbol of
liberals attacks on a murder remember
that when they come for you our broken
health care system failing
infrastructure outside attacks on our
democracy now for fox news it's trans
athletes the war on christmas colin
kaepernick and now the culture war
tucker carlson can't get a woody because
his m ms won't wear a thong maybe he
likes the sexy boots
america has systemic problems but
they're not m m's they're goobers
[ __ ] crazy ass [ __ ] tucker carlson
you are a dumb [ __ ]
now now what's funny is that he's gonna
you know he did the whole eminem thing
and then yesterday you guys seen that
the president
called
call i want to say but it's peter
douchey right but douchey and then peter
douchey
and then his name douchey
he leans into the mic the president
leans in the mic goes that stupid son of
a [ __ ]
i mean he didn't even [ __ ] he didn't
he didn't hold his hand over the mic he
didn't [ __ ] move his head
he didn't really even try to whisper it
under his breath
biden just leans into that [ __ ] mic
and says that's stupid son what a stupid
son of a [ __ ]
[ __ ] douchey what a dumb [ __ ]
we'll get to that oh we're get we're
gonna get to that [ __ ] story don't
worry about that you know we're gonna
report that here on the tony michaels
podcast during the [ __ ] let's round up
where we round up all the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends um let's see uh
here here's a recount let's see grant
has if